aquí tenemos una recta numérica y nos
preguntan qué número es menor que 6
tenemos el 6 marcado en esta recta
numérica y tenemos que ver si el 9 el 3
o 7 es menor bueno los números que están
a la izquierda del 6 son menores que 6
el 5 está a la izquierda del 6 en la
recta numérica así que es menor que 6 el
4 es menor que 6 el 3 es menor que 6 y
todos los que siguen a la izquierda son
menores que 6 y por otro lado vemos que
los números que están a la derecha del 6
en la recta numérica son mayores que 6
el 7-8 9-10 y todos los que siguen a la
derecha son mayores que 6 vemos cómo se
incrementan si nos movemos hacia la
derecha el 7 es mayor que 6 el 8 es
mayor que 6 el 9 es mayor que 6 el 10 es
mayor que 6 y lo mismo con todos los que
siguen hacia la derecha volviendo a la
pregunta que número es menor que 6
aquí tenemos 9 que es mayor que 6
el 3 es menor que 6 está a la izquierda
del 6 en la recta numérica y 7 es mayor
que 6 y en la vida diaria cuando piensas
que tienes 3 cosas tienes menos cosas
que alguien que tiene 6 cosas en la vida
cotidiana cuando tienes por ejemplo 3
plátanos tienes menos plátanos que
alguien que tiene 6 plátanos